we welcome you back to CBS morning's
candidates have been making their final
push with the polls opening this morning
in these crucial midterm elections
President Joe Biden and former president
Donald Trump delivered their closing
messages at rallies last night and for
the first time we also heard house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi described the
moment she learned about the horrible
attack on her husband at their San
Francisco home Pelosi told Anderson
Cooper at CNN it was around five o'clock
in the morning when she was awakened by
a loud repeating repeated rather
knocking on her door in Washington
so I run to the door and
I'm very scared I see this Capitol
Police and they said we have to come in
to talk to you and I'm thinking my
children my grandchildren I never
thought it would be Paul
they came in at that time we didn't even
know where he was or what his condition
was we just knew there was a an assault
on him in our home
for me this is really the hard part
because
Paul was not the Target and he's the one
who's
paying the price it really
it's really sad because it is
a fan a flame that was fueled by
misinformation there's obviously been a
lot of discussion about whether you'd
retire if Democrats lose the house well
I have to say my decision will be
affected about what happened the last
week or two
we are joined Now by CBS News
contributor Mick Mulvaney and CBS News
political contributor that's Ashley
etyan along with chief White House
correspondent Nancy Cordes good morning
and welcome to you all let's start with
you Ashley if we could because it was
heartbreaking she's clearly very
traumatized she became you know somewhat
emotional during that interview last
night what did you think when you were
watching her as someone who knows her
well well I couldn't help but also be
emotional you know it was hard to watch
her I know her to be very strong and
very Resolute so that was hard I mean I
think the the one thing we have to if we
could take a step back you know this
Congress opened up with a deadly attack
on the Capitol and threats to hang the
vice president of the United States it
was book End by an attack on the speaker
in her house her husband in her house
no matter how the elections turn out
today this is an issue that we're going
to have to Grapple with as a nation
we're going to have to figure out how do
we get back to a we not in US versus
them which is perpetuating this violence
so that was my top takeaway from it my
heart goes out to the speaker I know how
much she loves her husband and how much
she loves this country so I was
heartbroken by it but as a nation we
have to figure out we as American people
it won't be an elected official that's
going to save us here we're going to
have to say enough is enough yeah and
how do you how do you speak to that Mick
could you about the US versus we because
it is very concerning it is nothing
actually it's right it's not going to be
a politician that that saves us for lack
of a better word one politician didn't
get us into this problem one politician
is not going to get us out people ask me
how do you fix Washington I'm like
Washington doesn't really lead
Washington reflects the nation the
reason Washington is so divided is that
the country is how do you fix that it's
a harder question but don't look to
Washington to fix this look to us to fix
it but when it comes to the election
deniers though most that primarily is a
Republican Party and that I think has
led to many problems no that's that's
not true look January 6 is is what it is
it was awful it's terrible that's that's
not I'm not here to defend that but
Democrats have denied election results
just as much as Republican hands if you
take January 6 out of the equation yeah
well that's just factually not true I
mean there are hundreds of Republican
candidates on the ballot tonight who
have denied the outcome of the last
election there's nothing like that Stacy
Abrams still hasn't admit she lost last
time she ran in Georgia look again this
is the debate right right right why
can't we all agree that everybody's a
little bit at risk a little bit at Falls
when we try and fix it as opposed to
everybody's saying well it's got to be a
republican fault and until they change
the country's not going to fix Nancy I
want to get to you in a bit but Mick I
want to touch on something you said you
said politicians they can't save us but
they sure can divide us
um and we hope that politicians reflect
this country but it seems like instead
of a reflection it's an injection of
divisiveness so why don't you believe
that Paul politicians are at the the
Crux of why we are so divided why it is
US versus them during this time of year
because all times of year to be honest
with you politicians derive their power
from the people that vote for them
there's no magic sort of black dark hand
of invisible hand in Washington D.C
looking to the Extremes in both parties
and saying send me Marjorie Taylor green
and send me AOC that's not how it works
the people in those districts look at
those people and say those are the folks
that best represent me why don't we send
them to Washington D.C that's that's
what I struggle with so in the interview
yesterday last night Nancy Pelosi said
that what has happened to her husband
will affect her decision about whether
she will remain in politics what do you
think how do you think she's leaning
because the way she said it on one hand
you could say she's not going on
anywhere right on the other hand she
said she seem to be saying I've had
enough you know this is deeply affected
my family well there have long been
questions about whether she would
actually stay and serve out this term if
her party does does lose control of the
house you know does she really want to
be House minority leader again at the
same time for some years now there have
been younger members of the party who
have been pushing for new leadership at
the top they want somebody fresh they
want someone new at the same time you
know it's always been difficult to
identify who's the person in the
Democratic party who has her negotiating
skills her relationship her fundraising
ability her ability to bring a very
rambunctious party together there have
been some names that have been floated
Hakeem Jeffries of New York Adam Schiff
of California and there's also a
question about what her deputies would
do if she were to step down uh James
Clyburn of South Carolina and steny
Hoyer of Maryland they're both in their
80s as well Ashley as we anticipate the
Republicans being favored to win the
house there already is some finger
pointing when it comes to messaging
among the Democrats what is something
that you wish they would have done
differently no I think that's it it's
accurate I mean I think there's a lot of
frustration within the party folks feel
like we should have leaned more into the
economy inflation others feel like we
did a great job of sort of doing a d
strategy and all the above messaging I
mean my I would have advised a president
differently
um he had really big wins on a
bipartisan in a bipartisan way probably
the most productive first term we've
seen in modern history of any president
I would have advised him to find a way
to elevate those bipartisan successes in
those accomplishments wrap his arms
around Republicans that he did that with
right and then to demonstrate to the
American people that democracy can still
work that we can still do big things
together you know the president ran on a
message of healing that seems to have
been lost but I think had he sort of
come together with Republicans to say
look you know America democracy still
works not that it's under threat but
what's under threat is the progress that
we've made together both Democrats and
Republicans I think that would have gone
a long way it would have also helped to
neutralize the Extremes in both parties
and build a bigger broader Coalition for
him going into the midterms in 2024
right there are Extremes in both parties
and some people when they think extremes
they think Donald Trump who's made it
very clear he has a big big announcement
big big announcement we all believe that
it's huge we always know what that
announcement is we all believe he's
going to run as someone who knows him
well do you think that he should lead
the Republican party again though I've
said that very very care I think he's
the only Republican who can lose in
2024. my party is ready for generational
change we have really really good folks
on the bench Ron DeSantis Tim Scott
Nikki Haley Mike Pompeo Mike Pence go
down the list which are the Republican
priorities be at this point right now
priorities should be generational change
we have we can get the policies of
Donald Trump without having Donald Trump
on the ticket if Donald Trump's on the
ticket the election will be about him
either vote for him or against him in
All Candor no one voted for Joe Biden in
2020 they either voted for or against
Donald Trump Donald Trump is one of the
few people who can beat Donald Trump if
he's on the ticket the election becomes
about him instead about the issues that
we want to push when we had a chance
this time around to push the issues we
want to talk about inflation and crime
and safety we're doing well we don't get
that chance one thing we know for sure
he still has influence on the Republican
Party Donald Trump on line two for you
Mick and support us Ashley Etienne and
of course Nick mavaney thank you so much
for joining us